[Music]
ryan i want to talk to you about two
quick ways to save money on every
purchase okay
so what buns
you know what's funny is i don't do
coupons
i know and the reason i don't is because
i have found in my own life i'm not
prescribing this to anyone else but i
have found that in my own life
if i cut coupons save coupons join
rewards or loyalty programs
by and large when i do those things they
actually encourage more spending of
course they do yes they absolutely do
and that's what they're designed to do
right yeah and so i have two quick ways
i'm alabama i want to talk to you about
this here in a second as well so
professor sean make sure her microphone
is on
[Laughter]
so whether it's furniture or appliances
or
any non-consumables
i the first thing that i will do is i
will incorporate the 30 30 rule that we
just talked about yeah if it costs more
than 30
i'm gonna wait at least 30 hours i'm
going to wait for it and
sometimes the way that i'll do that is
i'll put something in my cart uh if i'm
saying i'm shopping somewhere i want to
buy something online i'll put it in the
shopping cart
and then i'll go back to that shopping
cart the next day and i'll delete all
the items where i'm like oh i'm so glad
i didn't buy that thing yeah and so the
30 30 rule or the wait for it rule helps
me avoid the clutter before it ever
enters my front door or shows up on my
doorstep yeah so that's the first thing
the second thing that i do is i've i'm
much more comfortable now buying high
quality items used sure i'm going to
talk to you in a moment about how i just
sold all of my furniture yeah as we were
moving yeah it was this awesome
experience in fact you know what we can
we can talk about it right now and i
think it'll be part of this little
little two-step way to save money
because
when bex and i were moving my landlord
at our apartment in l.a
he came in to do his little walk through
and he says i have rented hundreds of
apartments to hundreds of people
and this is the nicest looking apartment
i've seen who does your interior design
i was like oh i do and he's like what
would it cost to like buy all this
furniture from you i'm like what
he's like seriously if i wanted to buy
all of this furniture everything in here
what would it cost me and so i'm like i
don't know man
a lot of this and then i got a little
clingy at first right because well wait
a minute this my identity's tied up into
my my couch and my my table yeah and you
spent so much time like curating all
those things and it's art we're gonna
talk about that on the maximal episode
this week how the furniture that i enjoy
the most are also they double as art
pieces it's form and function absolutely
and i think that's where minimalism
really comes in to
uh helping us simplify our lives
is the form follows function i'm sorry
yeah form follows function right quite
often the opposite can get us into
trouble or we have some uncomfortable
things but they look beautiful right or
they get in the way
and so we'll talk about that as well
ryan on the private podcast this week
but i'm now much more comfortable buying
used things i'll give you an example
here as and so as my my landlord kenny
said i want to buy everything i said
sure i'll put together a list of
everything that we have in here
thankfully i don't own a whole lot so i
was able to actually just put together a
spreadsheet which he was so impressed by
like it's just a it's just uh google
sheets
it's everyone has access to it yeah yeah
but you are the spreadsheet king though
thank you i remember back in the
corporate i was concatenating formulas i
very much admired your spreadsheet
skills
well thanks but i um
i just put together a very simple spread
she said hey here are the here's
everything i own and here's what it
would cost brand new now that it's used
here's what i'm willing to sell it to
you for and he was like okay yeah i'll
buy it yeah and then that twinge came
back again
and i realized like oh no
but wait maybe and then i realized oh no
here's here's the truth
over the last dozen years or so
i've built up this special superpower
and it's called letting go yeah amen and
i think that you must be willing to let
go of
anything
to regain everything
you could tweet that sean
and i think
quite often when we cling to something
it prevents us from gaining what we want
to gain doing what we want to do
experience what we want to experience
having what we want to have and then
what do we do we cling tighter right
i really liked all the furniture that i
had and it was rather appropriate for
the home that we lived in for the last
five or so years
but it was less appropriate going into
this new sort of forever home where in
fact we're going to talk about forever
homes on the maxwell episodes a question
about forever homes right and what does
that mean exactly yeah but bex and i
found our forever home and what we
realized is like some of these things
wouldn't actually be appropriate we'd be
cramming them into this space and
because we don't own much we'll slowly
slowly populate the new space over the
course of the next year or two
until it feels right for us
and so here's the second way to
save money on every purchase we talked
about the 30 30 rule the other way is to
buy things used now the two place that i
i go facebook marketplace and i just
found this um
nuguchi um coffee table which are really
expensive if you buy them new
uh he was a american designer back in
the 20s 30s 40s 50s
and it's a piece of art it's a beautiful
table
but it's thousands of dollars if you buy
it new yeah
and i found a facebook marketplace for a
few hundred bucks nice two scratches on
it um which casino yeah there's some
character to it right oh yeah we'll talk
about it uh i think in the maximum of
the rick owens video oh yes but i love
it like he's going through all he's so
he's a designer and he's going through
his home
uh his office specifically he was like
you know i moved in here like this
um i haven't painted anything i haven't
refinished anything he's like these
little dents and scratches he's like i
love it i love the patina
i'm like there is a charm too i mean
there is dude the um
oh i forget his name and ohio famous
famous furniture maker uh something t's
david t smith i think okay um but uh i
know people that worked for him and like
you should see the contraptions that
they have the tools that they have to
create patina
on this furniture i mean you're talking
about like a club with like nails and
screws and like just and they just sit
there and they just they don't beat the
hell out of it but like they sit there
and they like add patina to a little bit
here a little bit there and yeah or like
um yeah it's crazy man they've really
come up with some unique things to
create this faux patina it sounds like
those anger rooms but a very light
version of that yeah have you got i
think you've gone to one of those
haven't you no i you know no no i
haven't has an escape room ever turned
into one of those for you you just
started hitting her
no but it's just funny because i
remember when i was a kid i would get so
mad
that um i remember it i remember um
fantasizing about anger rooms
and it's just funny how like now they're
actually a thing they are you have to
put on like protective gear and eyewear
and then you have like a bat or a
chainsaw i don't know what you do to go
into the room yeah and we won't put a
link to it in the show notes no we won't
but it sounds like a lot of fun hey with
the right attitude any room can be an
anger room
i think the same same is true with a
calm room yeah or a bathroom
[Laughter]
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free